ma non è possibile gli ho comprato ieri
edo hai visto i miei biscotti no fasi
vero casino non riescono a prendere
sonno sono le 3 del mattino dai non è
possibile ed ho la tavoletta quante
volte te lo devo dire dove il
telecomando ma sei più vicino guarda e
proprio in linea d'aria sei più vicino
tu allora ragazzi meno male che siete
tutti qui perché io vi devo parlare non
ne posso più io non sono la vostra donna
delle pulizie
adesso voglio proprio vedere se mi
rubano al cibo
[Musica]
devo farti una domanda ma ti prego
rispondimi sincera venezia
a te
funzione wi fi no allora siamo proprio
nella merda io sto per cucinare qualcosa
mancia che tu sei grazie volentieri vuoi
qualcosa in particolare
no non fai tu ok allora magari un pò di
pollo no è il polo non mi piace lo sai e
una pasta va bene basta la sera dai
pesante un'insalatina sera e chi sono un
coniglietto ascoltami un attimo vai a
farti cucinata tua madre ma sai che non
c'avevo pensato e se la chiamo bella
vita la loro canto c'è una stronza
perché la vecchia t di tutti bello
arriverà di tutto bene
ciao le senti lo so che sono le 10 del
mattino però seconda serata devastante
da curiosa e quindi fate poco casinò mar
mi raccomando a un'altra cosa si è
beccato uno sconosciuto in bagno
tranquilli javier taglierino argentino
ti hanno insegnato distinguere stavolta
vai tu a vicino a te guarda no ma se mi
fai farà fare un passo in più
inutilmente poi io oggi contro il ciclo
sto malissimo freddo ti prego
scusa cosa stai facendo
metto la pellicola a costituire con peli
pubici in bagno pile di piatti da lavare
la polvere ovunque che sono allergica e
tra un po muoio
ma questo era detto che ognuno la nuova
altri piatti tra è cosa siete in vacanza
ad essere stato avanti da tre settimane
solo io e cosa fai stasera esco e dai
big anch'io è una serata solo donne
nessuno ti avrebbe invitato adoro le
serate solo donne
gli esperti sono pronto e do dopo fare
la pipì di dzeko si dieci minuti e ci
sono e ascolta aiuti che lasci lì perché
oggi tocca a te la valle lo sai come tu
camera fitto ca te ea che dici io gli
armati l'altro ieri
e allora ha dato cassiano casa round io
miglioro dice no video tutti premi juno
biglietti per evitare questi
inconvenienti a inizio anno se vi
ricordate la un fatto tutti insieme
eravate tutti presenti o per planning e
ogni giorno qualcuno faceva qualcosa
adesso siamo arrivati al punto in cui
ogni giorno io faccio qualcosa che non
va bene
14 cm bello mio ti ho scoperto o non
farti da di non capire lo sai benissimo
il wifi lai posizionato 14 cm più vicino
alla sostanza rispetto alla mia
quello che a me non prende mai
[Musica]
abbassa la musica sto cercando di
dormire
[Musica]
smetti di gridare sto cercando di
ascoltare la musica ciao lava i piatti
[Musica]
di cuore il cuore i tuoi coinquilini non
ci sta tutto e scrivi con con cui
conquistò a jean con qui era lo capisce
siamo noi se non mi interessa ormai
dalle favole sai che succede che il wifi
me lo metto direttamente dentro la
camera così impari merda ve lo ripeto
un'ultima volta così lo capite tutti e
spero di non doverlo più ripetere con
molta calma io non sono la vostra
lavastoviglie non sono una lavatrice
io non sono la vostra donna delle
pulizie io non faccio più niente va bene
[Musica]
siete proprio de gli schizzinosi
ovviamente è sempre io devo fare le cose
lo saprete che si auguri e un bagno
[Musica]